a moment of victory for libyan
government forces
and another setback for warlord khalifa
fighters officials in tripoli say their
forces
have taken back alawatia air base near
tunisia's border
it has been under haftar's control since
2014.
the base is within 50 kilometers of
three towns
zintanzawara and assa its location had
made it difficult
for government forces to find a secure
area where they launched
ground and airstrikes to retake the base
in early may
the fighting resulted in heavy losses on
both sides
the military says the turning point came
when it destroyed at least
two of haftar's russian-made air defense
systems
it's a game-changer in terms of the last
uh year
of khalifa hafter's offensive um from
on tripoli and i think in that sense we
have to understand how it's changed
the military calculus now um hafta had
imported
um two russian air defense systems there
in recent days
um in order to safeguard it and that
tells you the value of that asset to
felipe after
they fought bitterly over this asset
since 2015 in fact since the first
civil war that was sparked by khalifa in
2014
now it's a major development because it
really alters the way in which hafta can
continue his offensive on tripoli hafta
took control of al-watiya air base in
2014
that's when he called on libyans to rise
up against the unrecognized government
in tripoli since then he's used
it for his headquarters for his forces
in western libya
haftar has been launching strikes there
since april 2019
to support his offensive to seize
control of the capital
an offensive that's killed more than a
thousand people
hafta continues to launch strikes on
tripoli and its motega airport
only eight kilometers east of the city
but he no longer has
any air bases in the west while he still
controls
large swathes of land in oil fields
across eastern
and southern libya but analysts say the
recapturing of al-watiya air base
may tip the balance of power in the
government's favor
since it no longer has to defend the
west and can focus
on the capital law about a manly al
jazeera